it's underwater weeks now
[Music]
Putin has a trick up his sleeve and he's
finally using it
it's a weapon he's been holding on to
for years waiting for this moment
[Music]
the weapon is this umbilical cord that
ties Russia to Europe infrastructure and
fuel now a weapon of War
it starts up here in this freezing cold
part of Russia where under the snow and
ice there's energy from plants and
animals that lived a hundred million
years ago now stored in the cracks of
rocks thousands of meters underground
from here it is sucked up and sent
through pipes that are in land and water
all the way to Europe where it is burned
in power plants to boil water to turn
turbines and make electricity to keep
the lights on in Europe the gas is also
burned right in European homes to cook a
meal or to heat a home oh and it's not
just one big pipeline natural gas moves
through a mind-bogglingly massive
network of pipes linking Russia to
Europe
foreign
[Music]
what I want to do here is quickly get
you up to speed on what is happening and
how these pipelines have been turned
into a weapon in a weird version of
hybrid Warfare
we call it hybrid because you have two
things going on here you've got this
traditional old school style war playing
out it's got artillery and foot soldiers
and cruelty against civilians give the
conquest and annexation of land that's
like old school style war and yet Putin
hasn't declared an official War he's
covering this whole thing up back home
calling it a special military operation
while simultaneously stealing a bunch of
land in Ukraine and drafting hundreds of
thousands of Russians to the battlefield
as someone who studies conflict this has
gripped me because it's playing out not
just on these battlefields but on a
bunch of other battlefields too energy
markets infrastructure Financial systems
and information sharing on the internet
that simply has never existed before
like this and it's on these battlefields
where the big nuclear powers of our
world are going head to head in an
increasingly dangerous way so I'm going
to walk you through the moves and the
counter moves of this hybrid War so that
we can understand how Vladimir Putin has
turned these pipelines into a weapon of
War on Europe's ongoing energy crisis
leaders in the region Gathering the
Russian Energy company gas pump
drastically reduces
before we continue I want to thank
today's sponsor nordvpn who makes a
product I deeply appreciate and use all
the time the VPN allows you to access
content from different countries like I
can watch like Netflix as if I were a
British person in the UK because I
connected the internet via the UK but
that's just one of many features when
I'm traveling I like to connect to the
internet via the United States so that
my email doesn't kick me out thinking
that I'm like a hacker in a different
country this makes my life so much
easier the best part is it's super easy
you click one button and you are
connected you can even just auto connect
so it just does it in the background
lately Nord has become even more useful
to me because it is now a threat
protection tool it blocks intrusive ads
and web trackers it inspects your files
that you download for malware it scans
URLs and blocks anything malicious all
in the background so that you can surf
the Internet and feel safe and secure
these features protect your devices but
also you and your personal information
and if you want to try it out there's a
link in my description clicking this
link helps support this channel but it
also gets you four months of free
nordvpn on the two-year plan best part
is you can try it out for free for 30
days and get all your money back if it's
not useful to you let's get back to the
moves and counter moves of the war in
Ukraine first thing to note here this is
not just a war between Russia and
Ukraine it's also a war between Russia
and a huge group of countries that we're
calling the West Russia started it but
now both sides are engaged in a complex
game of 4D chess or maybe more
accurately we could call it a high
stakes game of chicken so let's look at
the moves and counter moves on either
side and try to make sense of why I'm
calling these boring pipelines a weapon
as we know this really started in
February on a physical Battlefield with
a full-scale Invasion
the superpowers in the west couldn't
intervene directly with like troops and
stuff because that would risk an
escalation between nuclear countries but
they also couldn't let Russia just do
this so the West counter move to
Russia's invasion was to cut Russia off
from a huge number of its economic ties
to the world European union and its
partners are working to [ __ ] pujin's
ability to finance his War Machine the
second thing the West did as retaliation
for The Invasion looks like this
my Administration authorized another 200
million dollars to keep a steady flow of
weapons and ammunition moving to Ukraine
money and weapons and intelligence
support and ammunition into Ukraine to
help them fight this War I mean look at
this this this this yes I print
Wikipedia articles sometimes like why
did I print it because I like to look at
it in physical form makes me feel smart
this massive document is the list of
foreign aid to Ukraine during this war
and by foreign aid we mean like weapons
and ammunition I printed it in black and
white I really want color flag that's
the whole reason I printed it can we
reprint this I need color Flags I'm
going to print a new one with colored
Flags okay here it comes pressing print
I'm getting my color list
no I didn't print every single page I
just printed a few
just really like color Flags the point
is that none of us can fathom how much
military hardware has been delivered by
the West to ukrainians to fight this war
if you just glance at a few pages of
this meticulously built Wikipedia
article it just starts to blow your mind
like who knew that Portugal was giving
10 million euros worth of Military
Support to Ukrainian Armed Forces wait
till you get to the United States
section of this thing not only is it
billions and billions and billions of
taxpayer dollars but then it's loads of
really Advanced Equipment Javelin
anti-tank missiles five helicopters 200
shotguns 200 machine guns 40 million
rounds of small arms ammunition just a
thousand pistols 400 machine guns
anti-personnel munitions
sounds horrible 15 tactical Vehicles 50
armored Humvees by the way can we all
just appreciate that we live in a time
where there are people who spend their
days assembling all of this on an open
source platform like Wikipedia so that
all of us can read it and yes we have to
go and fact check it and make sure it's
well sourced all glory be to the people
who assembled this list
so not surprisingly Putin is not loving
all of this support
so this was the West counter move it was
sanctions and unfathomable amounts of
military hardware sent to Ukraine but
wait let's be clear What's Happening
Here the West is not giving billions of
dollars worth of weapons and support to
Ukraine out of the goodness of their
hearts this is a calculated response in
an escalating conflict the West has to
show their adversary Russia that there's
a cost to all of this Behavior otherwise
Putin would get really comfortable
stealing land but again the West can't
interfere directly so they've been
forced to fuel this conflict using
Ukraine as their proxy to push back
Russia oh boy here comes the backlash
yes I just called this a proxy war and
lots of people in the west don't really
like to frame it this way because it's
literally a talking point of Russia's
foreign minister that this is a proxy
war from the west but that's what it is
let's be real about it it really is the
West's only move here it's the best
thing we could do international
relations nerds I will see you down in
the comments for a nice healthy debate
on this point the rest of us let's move
on a senior NATO official is warning
that a potential Russian nuclear strike
would almost certainly trigger a
physical response from many allies so
needless to say things are kind of
escalating in this conflict
Putin keeps flexing saying that he's
considering using nuclear weapons and
reminding us that he's very serious okay
wait a minute this whole like I'm not
bluffing like isn't that exactly what
someone says when they're bluffing Putin
get a better Poker Face bro he's not
using nukes anytime soon and God I hope
I'm not wrong on that like imagine the
apology video I'll be making if I'm
wrong on this prediction
anyway the point I'm trying to make here
is that nukes are not the next move for
Putin he's got one more massive trick up
his sleeve and it looks like this these
pipelines and the gas that flows through
them these pipelines are the umbilical
cord between Russia and Europe they are
the result of years of a mutually
beneficial relationship because Russia
who's got tons of natural gas is able to
serve the demand in European countries
who have built their economies off of
that natural gas for a long time this
was a very mutually beneficial
relationship I mean look at all these
European leaders and Putin in 2012 and
they're talking about this new pipeline
they're opening and they're Giddy and
excited because they're all cooperating
on energy Putin gets loads of money
Europe gets natural gas to build their
economy off of everyone's happy I
believe in natural gas gas will be
supplied directly by the shortest route
linking the major Russian gas reserves
to European markets we can guarantee
this but it turns out this was a trap
what it ended up doing is putting a huge
amount of Leverage in the hands of this
guy
a weapon that he's now using in this war
Putin's government has a controlling
stake in the biggest gas company in
Russia which means that Putin himself
can give the order to turn off the Taps
on these pipelines turn them off and
that's exactly what he did European gas
prices again reached near record highs
it is indefinitely holding the flow of
gas to a key pipeline working hard to
become independent of disgust Supply and
the question I always have when I hear
this big news of like prices and I see
graphs is like what does this actually
mean for European to understand that you
have to look at one more graph what we
see here is that Europeans need their
natural gas most in the winter when they
burn that gas to heat their homes or to
make electricity to keep their lights on
during darker days but it's not just
heating homes this cheap abundant gas
from Russia has been a foundational
aspect of European economies especially
in Germany which by far is the most
reliant on this cheap gas from Russia
you just got to look at a place like
this it's a town that is basically just
a giant chemical plant in Germany it's
the biggest gas guzzler in the country
but I mean like come on chemical plant
kind of sounds boring unimportant right
like we can do without chemicals for a
bit while we get through this crisis no
no no no no no that's what I thought for
a moment I was like chemicals that
sounds like like some like like what are
people doing chemistry in there with
natural gas like I was I was not aware I
started tracing down all of the products
that are linked to this specific German
chemical plant and it's wild I mean next
time you're driving down the road you
see one of these like weird looking
buildings with a bunch of pipes give it
like a salute because inside of this
plant they're making ammonia which is
used to make fertilizer which is used to
grow your food they make the Menthol for
your toothpaste and they make tons of
chemicals that are necessary for
building cars which is Germany's biggest
export I didn't really grasp this before
but I now see that our modern industrial
economy is like founded on chemicals and
you need a lot of natural gas to make
chemicals so as Russia strangles Europe
from natural gas it's having an effect
on paper and steel and so much more you
need energy for all this stuff so when
the cost of energy goes up the cost of
everything goes up inflation and soaring
prices are biting hard price of olive
oil has gone up by 27 consumer prices in
Germany reach eight percent higher than
one year earlier that's a level not seen
since the 1970s oil crisis and this is
exactly what Putin wants this is his
next move in the war and notice the
timing here it's about to get really
cold in Europe another mind-blowing fact
here is that 70 percent of the energy
that is used by European households is
just to heat the home 70 and about half
of European homes rely on natural gas
for heat and where does that natural gas
come from Russia well no not Russia it
doesn't come from Russia anymore it now
needs to come from somewhere else
somewhere that doesn't have a bunch of
pipelines that can pipe it in cheaply
it's either that or Europeans freeze
this winter cue the current panic in
Europe
[Music]
two of our producers Jack and paji were
recently in Berlin and I asked them to
go look for electric heaters to see if
like it was easy to buy them like is
this Panic real is this thing on
hey Johnny we're about to like walk into
an electronic store and see if this is
actually true and people are buying
these electric heaters like crazy
[Music]
um
this is actually happening they had like
five or six still in the store on
display but he said they have nothing
left back in storage and once those five
or six radiators are sold they're not
getting new ones electric heater sales
all over Germany seem to be going up 76
this year over last by one estimate okay
but I hate to break it to you Germany
the electricity that you need to run
these electric heaters is now way more
expensive too because natural gas is
also used to make electricity and it
drives up the price for all other forms
of electricity as well so yeah Putin
played his big wild card in this
economic War by turning off the Taps and
let's walk through his calculations here
because it wasn't just to like make
Europeans suffer as payback he has an
end game his goal is that by doing so
the people will get fed up and go to
their leaders and be like why are we
supporting a war in Ukraine at our own
expense and Under Pressure the leaders
in Europe would then fracture and be
more likely to go to president zielinski
who they have lots of Leverage over and
pressure him into making a deal with
Putin just stop the war give Putin all
the land that he's annexed and move on
President Putin has announced the
annexation of four regions of Ukraine
that are controlled by Russian forces in
the biggest seizure of territory in
Europe since the second world war and
this would mean a big win for Putin
moves and counter moves that's what this
is and let me just say Putin's plan is
not not working
[Music]
this is happening right now and it's
changing every day so by the time you're
watching it boy things could have
changed but there is a growing movement
especially in Germany to protest these
sanctions and this military aid to
Ukraine
[Music]
[Applause]
they're fed up with higher prices
for something they don't think is worth
it
and as winter comes and the demand for
gas increases to heat homes and keep the
economy alive this tension will only get
worse just as Putin planned using his
energy weapon just at the right time to
inflict the most amount of pain on
Europe's economy science
okay wait a minute did you catch this
we're talking about like high stakes
like global conflict and Putin is
invoking this folk tale in which a
clever Fox presumably Putin himself
outsmarts this dumb Wolf by tricking him
to going down to a frozen lake and
putting his tail in a hole in the ice to
try to like catch fish but eventually
the wolf's tail freezes and the Wolf is
stuck until a bunch of villagers come
down and beat him up by the way I talked
to a Russian about this and she told me
that like the fox is not portrayed as
like a role model here like the fox is
actually like a pretty unsavory and yet
Putin wants to be the fox and the EU is
the world
man he's he's just quite the Storyteller
so that is what is going down here in
this conflict it is hybrid Warfare with
a particular 2022 flavor something we've
never seen before and we don't really
know what happens next it's developing
right now but allow me to share with you
a few closing facts that we should keep
in mind that will help us make sense of
this economic war first turning off the
pipelines to Europe doesn't just hurt
Europe it hurts Russia too in the short
term they've been making tons of money
off of this surge in natural gas prices
but in doing so they have severed their
ties with their best highest paying
customer Europe they're now looking East
for new customers maybe in China and
India but none will pay the prices that
Europe was willing to oh and plus they
don't have nearly the network of
pipelines that they have into Europe
building those takes decades but somehow
this was worth it to Russia to inflict
short-term pain on Europe in exchange
for a long-term hit to Russia's gas
industry second and speaking of long
term yes this is painful for Europe
right now but what it's going to do is
quickly force them to look for new
places to find their energy spoiler
alert in the short term Qatar is going
to get Way Rich off of all of this
richer than they already are if you can
imagine but the point is that this will
accelerate Europe's already started
transition away from fossil fuels
they're now being forced to speed that
up in other words if they can weather
this difficult time they will come out
way better off than they did before and
Putin Will Come Away with way less
economic leverage over them and this
gets to my last point and this is a
little bit more of my opinion and
prediction on the situation which is
that this guy Vladimir Putin I think has
overplayed his hand once again using all
of his leverage in one swoop and
dramatically underestimating its ability
to work I mean just go back he
miscalculated his Army's ability to take
over Ukraine's Capital very swiftly he
miscalculated his Army's ability to hold
land he miscalculated the response of
the Ukrainian military and people to
resist his invasion he miscalculated the
response from the west and now it seems
like he once again has miscalculated his
ability to force to Europe to stop
supporting Ukraine through energy
blackmail he seems to be over five which
is good news Until you realize that
every time he loses one of these bets he
escalates the conflict what's scary is
that Putin can't lose he's not allowed
to if he loses he gets thrown out of
power back home so I think he'll keep
digging in his heels using all of the
tricks in his Arsenal I'm not totally
sure where it goes from here but I can
tell you that this conflict is far from
over
[Music]
thank you for watching this video and
you're still here look at you you're
still watching this video Even after
it's kind of over I am really excited
about what we're doing here we are
building more and more really exciting
videos and there are more people behind
the scenes than ever we have revamped
our patreon to give you more behind the
scenes of how this stuff is made how we
actually do this every month we release
a video that is just a kind of chaotic
way less sort of polished and edited
look at the behind the scenes here in
the studio and out in my travels take
this tripod to be our friend but the
real shining star the real behind you
glowing
what what's training what what's behind
me what's going on you get access to my
scripts you get access to like the uncut
version of my interviews with experts I
interviewed several experts for this
story that you didn't see they're super
informative you can see that on patreon
most importantly though patrons are
supporting this work they're allowing us
to do more of it to make it more
journalistically rigorous and factually
accurate that's what I want to do more
of I really believe in that I really
appreciate those who are supporting so
thank you all for being here I'm gonna
see you in the next one we've got a
million videos coming up and um boy it's
gonna be a busy winter have a good one
the end
[Music]